hello sweetie so here we are time for a
Big Finish review and this one was a box
set this is this no third box that I've
done now because I did a Fourth Doctor
adventures I think it was second season
that I did although I haven't finished
with that review because I've got
another part of that I have to cover but
I did the the war doctor now the diary
of River Song very wonderfully sent to
me by a by a supporter sent to my PO box
so that was awesome but yeah so this was
one that I knew of I actually didn't
know much of anything about the episode
in terms of whether or not people well I
kept aside the box set in terms of
whether or not people liked it the
impression I got was a little bit mixed
and having now heard it if that is the
case I can see why now a little bit
first um I I want to be clear I actually
quite liked River Song as a character in
general I know not everybody does she's
divisive sometimes I think some people
feel that she is exemplary of a lot of
Moffitt's not great writing instincts in
some of the directions he took things in
but I've always enjoyed her as a
character I think Alex Kingston plays
her very well that being said it was
very clear and listening to this that at
least at the time of recording for this
boxset she wasn't quite used to working
in audio as opposed to visually cuz this
hadn't occurred to me in advance but it
definitely hit me while I was listening
that a lot of what works about her in
episodes is sold on basically the eyes
like the little look she gives the
glances the grins the smiles and when
she doesn't have that I can hear that
she's like overcompensating in her voice
and her vocal delivery to try and bring
that stuff across knowing that people
can't see her and while they're not
horrible performances she is kind of
being outclassed by a number of her
co-stars at various points throughout
the whole thing and it's and it's the
kind of thing where I just kind of
presume she'd get better with practice
so I mean I know there have been like
well six or seven series of this thing
so far so I I suspect that she's
probably much better later on but in
this one and it's it's really kind of
iffy and then you know there's the
stories themselves so there's the first
one which is the boundless sea and it's
the weakest one of the lot
it it has a lot of it reminds me more
than a little bit of the sands of life
war with the land thing from from the
forth dr. box said because it very much
as soon as it sets things up it's just a
whole bunch of running and characters
shouting and that just isn't the kind of
storytelling that audio is cut out for
and actually that's something that's
gonna come up a little bit repeatedly as
I talk about these the four parts of
this thing but anyway the set up for the
first one is that it is set sort of
early 1900s you know when you know the
big archaeological digs were happening
Tutankhamen got uncovered and things
like that so River Song who is who is a
professor at this point is hiding out at
a university on earth she heads to an
excavation where a young assistant has
gone missing and she goes in to try and
find out what has gone on and she
encounters basically an a nice warm and
a revived mummy kind of character so the
setup is fair enough all things
considered but like I said as soon as we
establish that what technology brought
this mummy back and that it seeks out
any moisture at all whether it's you
know whether it's just water or whether
it is you know people sweat or tears or
whatever then from there it's just a
whole bunch of running and shouting
until it's defeated and it's just it's
just
not especially well-written the co-stars
are okay this character named birdie who
she gets teamed with who I actually
rather liked in this although things get
weird around him and some of the later
stories and I'll get to that in a minute
so the next one is called I went to a
lovely party which first of all I like
the starting setup and premise which is
river shows up on this ongoing party on
a ship that has been going on for years
that people just kind of drop in and out
of as they will which first of all
immediately reminded me of Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy I think it was the
third book I think it was life the
universe and everything that had the
party that never ended so it reminded me
a little bit of that but then it kind of
matches up to ideas which I mean I
suppose is better than taking an idea
that doesn't work in audio and
stretching it out for a full hour like
the previous one did but the thing is is
that these two ideas don't quite build
on each other properly because it's so
first we have kind of a locked door
mystery kind of thing because we're at
this party it's really hard to get in
and out of and somebody has died and so
we've got a mystery element and then in
addition to that River uncovers that the
people the sorts of people come to this
party the rich the powerful the
influential they fancy themselves the
rulers of the universe and they actually
deliberately and artificially tweak and
manipulate civilizations that have not
that are below a certain technology
level in order to quote-unquote
steer them in the in the right direction
and neither of these are bad ideas but
they don't inherently complement each
other and the story doesn't do a ton to
interweave them now I mentioned birdie
and in the last one in this one
he comes back because it turns out he's
actually one of the member and one of
the members of the rulers of the
universe and it's really weird I mean I
guess they did it to like create some
kind of a through-line between the
previous one and this one I don't think
it helps though because that's the only
thing that connects and honestly he
doesn't add anything and the way he
behaves is so completely different from
the way he behaved last time
explained with like he was being in
character previously and now he's just
him as he normally is but it it creates
a disconnect that is just was it even
worth having this be the same guy I'm
not sure it brings anything or adds
anything to it again that might have
worked better in a visual medium where
at least you know you'd be getting a
different performance but you'd still be
seeing the same person without that it
just comes across as was there any
reason for this to be the same guy as
before as far as the answers to the
solutions and things like that it's not
the most interesting in the world but
then again it is only an hour so the
mystery was only gonna be so complicated
and River is fairly clever in the way
she decides to deal with this now at the
very end she encounters a man who
presents himself to her as her husband
now kind of an interesting thing
happened at this point which is that I
just went ahead and popped in the next
CD but didn't bother to look at the
cover because if I had the cover of the
next one called signs all right there
see areas
that's the gentleman who was claiming to
be her husband and is calling himself
the doctor and that's no doctor we've
ever seen the thing is I popped it him
without looking at the cover so I didn't
realize this and I don't know if the guy
actually flat out sounds like Paul
McGann or if I just projected that onto
him because Paul McGann's on like the
cover proper of the whole box set but I
actually did think that this was McGann
for a while which is probably unintended
given you know that this other guy's
face is on the box but I actually think
gave me a better listening experience
that the reveal that this was not the
doctor was probably more of a surprise
than to me that it was actually meant to
be now as far as this episode go signs
it is the one that comes the closest to
doing the sorts of things that work best
in audio and that Big Finish is good at
in that it is a little bit more
complicated a little bit more intricate
it is sort of playing with some bigger
concepts the sort of things that would
be really hard to more really expensive
to do visually and not just because like
a big explosion just because
the sorts of things that like you can
see it in your head probably a lot
easier than it would be to visualize it
so it works pretty well on that front
but at the same time it still feels like
it was written in a way that would have
benefited more from a visual standpoint
what I mean by that is the that has more
to do with the way the story is
structured so the way science works is a
river and this fake doctor I think
official media hasn't just labeled this
mr. song so the two of them are going
after what are called the spore ships
which are these things that nobody knows
where they came from they they've been
around for ages they just go to plant it
and wipe them out no one has figured out
the pattern how to stop them what the
deal is and they're trying to do that so
Atlas at the start and I say starting me
in the start of the audio not the
chronological started the story which is
kind of where I'm getting but at the
start River has disabled something but
she has taken a massive dose of
radiation so she spends pretty much the
entire story dying and so she's in a
disabled state she's having wonky dreams
we're getting flashbacks parts of it are
told out of order and it is difficult to
follow as a result of that because and
again it's the sort of things where if
this was being told in visual medium
when you go to something like a
flashback or a dream it would be very
easy to have easy visual signifiers even
if it's just a sepia tone you know you
know over something to distinguish it
from what what was just going on what
just happened and without the easy
visual cues that we've shifted into a
dream or into a flashback or back to the
quote-unquote present it is not it
doesn't flow particularly smoothly and I
did spend a decent chunk of it going
wait what's going on but not in an
intrigue I can't wait to find out wait
and I'll wait a minute slow down I need
notes sort of way so that unfortunately
derailed it a little bit which is a
shame because I actually really like the
core concept of this one it's probably
the best idea even though the execution
falls down a bit I mean overall it's
probably still the best episode of the
box set but it even this one doesn't
fully come together for me some of the
ideas at the end and this is gonna start
to get a little bit more into proper
spoilers if you
Wow you know I think I can do without
bringing it up so some of the specifics
for exactly how this guy's manipulating
her beyond just claiming to be the
doctor are kind of interesting and
creepy and a little unsettling in a in a
cool sci-fi kind of way and I like the
what I like the idea I like the way that
was played out and it really it it felt
like it justified rivers anger um and
that was another thing that was kind of
nice I did for as much as I kind of rag
Don Alex Kingston's performance and like
I'm feeling like she's not used to
working in audio it is nice to stew here
River separate from the doctor so I get
a better sense of her when she's not
just playing off of him and you know the
little reminders that she is more
ruthless she does not have the same
problem taking lives she's not always
interested in saving everybody if she
can and you know getting that sort of
sense of coldness that she has when
dealing with basically anybody who isn't
the doctor and that was kind of cool to
see on more full proper display here
since you know she's not playing off of
him for a good chunk of this thing now
we get into the last one which is called
I have now suddenly forgotten that last
one is the rules of the universe now
this one it is base it's it's the
finality it serves as the to try and
bring everything together and this is
the one where Paul McGann actually shows
up and it's very much continuing
directly off the one previous we're
still dealing with the spore ships Plus
as the name implies we are also dealing
with the remnants of the rules of the
universe and that plotline from I went
to a lovely party now Wow
we get first of all McGann gives a great
performance he always does cuz he's just
he's been doing this a while he's really
good at it and there is unfortunately
there's a narrative lean necessitated
detachment between River and the doctor
which is unfortunately this is kind of
and even though Moffat himself didn't
write any of these this is sort of an
upshot of how Moffat was a little too
clever for his own good when it came to
River in that some of the things that
established really hamstrings what
stories can be told because we establish
that the doctor does not know River
properly until tenant so anytime you
have her interacting with any doctor
that isn't tenant there's two things
that can't happen
they can't know her name and they can't
see her cuz otherwise tenant would have
recognized her in silence in the library
and it doesn't end that doesn't work in
terms of the continuity so because of
that even though the two of them do know
they have dialogue together but then
they're never physically in the same
space and while their banter is pretty
good it does feel like a little bit of a
you know the story the story in and of
itself would have benefited from going
to heck with continuity let's just have
these two together and have a lot of fun
but because it is trying to maintain the
continuity it can't actually do that and
it is one of those times where I think
continuity continuity is a wonderful
thing when it works and sometimes it
gives you a lot of possibilities but
other times it can really kneecap a
story and cut off at the legs in terms
of where you can go and what you can do
because it limits your options and this
is a case where I think that bit it in
the butt a little bit but again it's
it's pretty good if I were to rank these
overall signs will go at the top even
though the the actual sort of order that
things happen in is a little bit clunky
and the transitions are and then after
that I would probably put rules of the
universe and then I went to a lovely
party and then boundless see at the
bottom and that's by a pretty decent
margin back boundlessly see like I never
want to listen to again the others I
would listen to again oh and the other
you'll point out I don't really like her
theme that they came up with it's very
much trying for like whoosh crikey
swashbuckling what kind of adventure
kind of thing um so I get the vibe
they're going for but it's just a little
too bombastic like I would see I'd have
to turn the volume down when the theme
kicked in cuz it was it was really loud
and really insistent on itself and I
didn't much care for it which is a shame
because some of these alternate themes
can work for
the war masters theme was brilliant but
I talked about that when I did that
review so I think I'll wrap up there I
think I got through most of that without
getting without spoiling some of the few
things that I think are worth keeping a
surprise and yeah diary of River Song
series one it's not bad I'm certainly
not um I'm so well I'm glad it was sent
to me I'm certainly glad that I listened
to it I'm kind of glad that I personally
didn't pay money for it so but I what I
will say is that it does make me curious
to hear a later series of it whether
it's the immediate next one or one of
the ones from down the line I don't know
if the story is ongoing across the
series if you have to listen to them in
order or not but like I would be very
curious to hear how this plays out once
Alex Keaton kind of has her feet under a
little bit better and is playing better
in this sort of medium cuz I think it
has enough potential that I want to see
it I want to see it happen again and the
and have them do better which given how
many series they are on so far I'm going
to assume that they did but for right
now this is all I've heard so this is
all I'm talking about
so the diary of River Song have you
heard it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it whole bunch of stuff you
can do because there's buttons and links
including one to the patreon there's the
peel box that I mentioned that address
is down there too
um check it out if you want other stuff
besides but if you don't want to that is
okay because at the end of the day
you're the council and I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]